[Music]
get to that let's introduce my co-host
for this episode nagin farsad nagine
welcome back
oh hi neil how are you
after your first visit to us you didn't
run away and not come back
you came back i i felt my head getting
like
larger with facts and knowledge and i
thought
let's do this again
okay one day your head will not sit on
the screen
you're doing the right thing i'm taking
measurements
nageem facade is a stand-up comedian and
so you just you have gigs right this is
like any standard comedian would have is
that correct
uh yeah like i have gigs
in normal times and and then in horrible
and horrible times i have zoom gigs zoom
gigs
well you're you're our zoom gig right
now so we're delighted to have you back
so nageen if i remember correctly you
wrote a book called
how to make white people laugh indeed
that's a crazy title
that's just crazy it's uh
i would like a comet to be named after
my book
we can make that happen and
uh also you host a podcast fake the
nation
that's right yeah these are very very uh
these are terms you just gotta you gotta
just pick up that book and listen to
that target because you wanna know what
the hell
where are you coming from
you'll enjoy them uh they'll they're
they're fun
uh but they have like you know just a
lot less science but you'll still love
them
and we have a friend of star talk
natalie starkey natalie welcome back
hi neil yeah you're our
comet expert and you're you're dialing
in
or zooming in from cambridgeshire
the uk all the way in england very cool
well welcome and many people don't know
that
uh you wrote our most recent space show
at the hayden planetarium which features
planets as
uh as objects and planets as
astronomical
um targets of interest so just thanks
thanks for coming in to do that
i just wanted that no and of course we
went to visit a comet as well because
how could i resist if we're going to go
and look at things on the solar system
i'm like we're getting in a comet in
there
so yeah exactly exactly so when the
planetarium opens back up and maybe
you come back and visit yeah i can't
wait i can't wait
can i give listeners a little bit of
insight about the two of you
the green room chit chat before we
started recording
was about helium ladies and gentlemen
exciting stuff that is what i mean
so if you think they're talking about
like you know kanye west or something
before we start recording
no they're talking about helium before
we start recording just so everyone's
clear
these people are talking about it all
day long
not just for this hour natalie starkey
is a colleague
and who's a professor at the uh is it
the open university
oh i'm actually i'm a public engagement
officer
yeah i'm at the open university so i do
a lot of physics public engagement
because
i discovered doing a lot of research i
actually just love talking about science
all the time right now okay what
actually doing it so much
very excellent and you've got a book and
you've got videos and so you're out
there
you're trying to do what what we're
trying to do so yeah i'm trying to copy
you but i just
take my place i'll go to the bahamas you
take my place how about that
okay all right so your expertise i'm
intrigued because your expertise in the
solar system
um grew up out of your expertise
thinking about earth as a planet
as a geological object so that gives you
a different kind of angle
into what comets are than an astronomer
would have so i'm intrigued by that
because you know i started out as a
geologist i've always been fascinated by
volcanoes that was what got me into
science
and then what i discovered from that is
i love doing chemistry on rocks and then
it just sort of grew from there and my
phd was looking at
understanding the earth as a planet how
it formed four and a half billion years
ago how it evolved
since then and so it was caught some of
the natural steps when i saw the postdoc
which is the research
position i had after my phd it was
looking at comet and asteroid samples
and doing the same kind of chemistry on
them
but it was just looking at space rocks
instead i thought oh my goodness that's
so cool i don't know anything about
space rocks but i'm going to jump in
and give it a go and i've just not
looked back since then i absolutely love
it i still love volcanoes
i don't mean to be biased but space is
cooler than geology
oh i don't know i think you need
geologists in space
you got to be careful because i hear
geologists can be very violent
so uh you might get some attacks after
this
you're just that they can float in like
actual rocks that they can touch
you can't touch your rocks neil we use
hammers a lot to break those rocks and
i've actually hit my own shin
with my own rock hammer before like when
i actually missed the rock it was so
painful so like yeah
i'm not breaking it nagin if she can do
that to herself i mean
imagine what she can do to others i've i
noticed a
like a hint of violence in you now
so so natalie you still have your
eyebrows so whatever
love of volcanoes you had you didn't
lean too far in to have no i know i
i very least i've never seen like an
actual eruption but i've been
on an active volcano many times and you
know just
a volcano in the caribbean that he works
on you can literally hear the thing
roaring as you're standing next to it
all the gas is escaping from it's
absolutely amazing i never knew that
before i actually went to one
and actually sort of had to understand
its temperature and look at it in detail
and measure its gases
but they're just they're fascinating i
love volcanoes and so we've got
volcanoes in the solar system
that are places other than earth so it's
cool to have you uh helping us through
this
because actually my book coming out next
year is all about space volcanoes so uh
so i've written yeah my second book's
just finished so it's
yeah going to be a world that comes out
but it's about all the volcanoes in the
solar system
made of ice all made of rock right ice
volcanoes that's right
spewing chunks of ice we think of
volcanoes as hot objects
but it's really just objects where
there's a lot of pressure right not a
fair
yeah it's basically the effort the body
makes to cool itself down but if that
thing is already cold and it just has to
be a little bit warmer inside and a bit
colder outside
that it wants to lose that heat by the
way can i say that space volcano is how
i uh described an ex-boyfriend who was
both a pothead and had a temper
so i didn't actually realize
it was a real thing so i'm learning a
lot right now yeah
i didn't know potheads have tempers that
was what was
remarkable that was what was weird about
him
you know so so nagin did you collect
questions for us for this cosmic queer
i did there's so many great questions um
let's head right in let's head right in
with uh
phillip lyons from patreon he asks i
understand
patreons go first because they really
support
i understand that comet neowise was
recently discovered in march
given how long its orbital period is
around the sun
how can we be sure that it originated in
our solar system
good one natalie that is yeah i always
i'm kind of always
nervous john cosmick queries because it
feels like an exam like i know this
stuff
and then i'm like oh my goodness what am
i gonna ask i'm so scared
like i do right i know it i know i know
the answer right um okay so
the thing about comments is so natalie
if i see you like peeking at your palm
with your hand that's what your notes
all right natalie you have about 30
seconds to answer this question and go
right so comments are really small let's
just get that out there first okay so
they're really hard to see in the solar
system
so when they're coming in towards the
inner solar system um
that's the only time we can really see
them in any detail quantify how small
how small uh well the near-wise is about
five kilometers across
so is that like three miles if you're in
albany um so
that's not huge if we're looking at that
from the earth and it's really far away
we're not going to see it very easily
um now most of the time comets live
really really far away they live in the
far
outer reaches of the solar system past
the orbits of all the planets
and they live in somewhere called the
kuiper belt and then even further out
this kind of theoretical region called
the oort cloud
and so there's lots of them out there
possibly billions of them
and sometimes they get diverted into the
inner solar system to bring them a bit
closer to the sun which is what happened
with neo-wise
now it comes in and actually it was on a
different orbital period to start with
but
its interaction with the sun changed its
orbital period so it got longer so i
think it's gone from
around 4 000 years to around 6 000 years
to get around the sun and all the way
back again
so it's a very it's a long period comet
is what we say
and this tells us that it came from very
far away because if it had come from
closer to us it wouldn't take so long to
go around the sun and so we worked out
it's all
orbital period and we know it's not
coming back for quite some time
and now what was the end of that
question if i answered that correctly
well wait so it's how do we know it's
from
this solar system and not concerned okay
so the reason we know it's from this
solar system
is mostly related to its speed now if
something was coming from another solar
system another star system
way out then it would be traveling
extremely fast to have exited its solar
system
and to be orbiting and to be traveling
through um the galaxy
now we've had that happen before there
was a an object that was called a
muammua
which was this strange object that we
saw very last minute
and we didn't know if it was a comet or
an asteroid we're still not 100 sure we
think it was probably a dead comet
and but it came from some other star
system and it traveled through our solar
system so
quickly that it didn't even get catched
into orbit around our sun it couldn't
have cared less that we were here it
just went straight through
zooming straight past so the fact that
we can kind of measure the speed or the
velocity of this comet in space and
neo-wise we can figure out it's come
from within our solar system
and we can roughly work out from where
it came and then where it's going back
to
all right so in other words if you
calculate it in orbit and it turned out
to be
infinity then it's never coming back
and it was an interloper right but yeah
you calculate the orbit and there's an
actual number that comes out of that
equation
with six or seven thousand years right
yeah
wait and it's just hanging out in this
spot
no what neo-wise no yes it's always on
this orbit so it's
some of them stay out in the outer solar
system but then occasionally comets get
kind of bumped into the inner solar
system because they might have
interacted with a big planet
and that kind of orbited past and kind
of threw them off their happy orbit
and then threw them towards the sun
essentially because the sun is really
big and so it's got tons and tons
it pulls out
gossip on the streets is the sun's real
big
it's actually 99.9 percent of the mass
of the solar system right
i was just going to say that but thank
you for saying that i can see you
so it pulls everything towards it and so
that's what happens with this comet if
it gets knocked out of its orbit it then
kind of comes hurtling towards the sun
they don't always go very close to the
sun there's still
some distance away um but if they get
too close they can get heated up so much
that they just disintegrate completely
which has happened quite a lot of times
but this one was safe it didn't go too
close and it managed to kind of skirt
around the sun and it's going back out
now it's on its way back out to the
outer solar system
all right all right well uh question
numero dos comes from um also from
patreon
ari maori uh says why is it comics
don't orbit in a circular orbit like the
planets do but instead have a very
elongated orbit
even though they all orbit the sun
shouldn't the comet orbit
uh like the planets the way out in the
oort cloud
uh you mentioned the oort cloud just now
by the way who names these clouds and
stuff because why is it named like brad
or larry
or something like why do they all have
these like you know science nerd names
i think the old clown was named after
yan or does that correct me
yes it is yes so it's named after
usually the person that discovers them
so if you discover something awesome
then you know you get to put your name
to it quite often which is
that's cool um or just i can add
out of respect for you if you make the
discovery then other people talking
about your research paper
will then coin that term so jan ort did
not say i've discovered the oort cloud
he didn't say that in his paper he just
did a calculation
and showed through all these comets that
come in from very long orbits and they
don't spend much time here
but if you look at the gravity of the
situation when you're far away from the
sun you're moving
slowly so then he did some math on this
and figured there must be a place out
there that has
billions of comments and those and all
in all directions around the sun and
then that paper gets published and
everyone said hey
there's this cloud of comments that yon
ort
hypothesizes and says it became the oort
cloud at that point
yeah so i'll come in on circular orbits
natalie what's up with that
so okay so most of the or all cloud
comets
are just sat out there and they're
basically forming this shell
around the solar system so if you
imagine all of the planets and the
asteroids they all sit in a plane um
and that's that's where we all kind of
circle around the sun they're all in the
same plane
pretty much anyway and then the creep
about
comets are also in that plane but then
the all cloud comets because they're so
far away they're not kind of bound to
the solar system by the gravity in the
same way that all the planets are
so they just form this shell and that's
pretty much how we know they're there
we've never been there we've never
directly observed them
in the alt cloud but sometimes when they
come into the inner solar system
they get diverted and they end up on
this very kind of elliptical orbit that
brings them
into the around the sun much closer and
that's how they end up on these and
that's how we know they're there because
they kind of come and visit us and then
they disappear again out to their home
in this shell around the solar system
are you suggesting that if all comets in
fact
did have circular orbits we would never
know they were there
because they would never come closer to
the sun rendered visible
by the by the heat of the sun yeah i
mean definitely the alt cloud ones of
course with the cove about we've now
been there because we've had um we had
the voyage emissions have gone
through the kuiper belt now and then
we've had um
the new horizons nasa mission that went
to visit pluto which is actually a
kuiper belt object it's not a comet
but it's this big dwarf planet sitting
out in the kuiper belt
negan those are fighting words she just
said that casually
you hear did you hear that in a game
pluto yeah it's a kuiper belt object
that's all
what's in the pepper belt
we've all been put on notice okay
that just slipped out of her mouth okay
the great thing about new horizons is it
went to look at another object
in in the kuiper belt so we got to see
this icy object that's sitting out there
so
we are actually now getting out there
and visiting these things and seeing
them in their home we don't have to wait
for them to come to us but
those missions are really tricky because
by the time you get out there you're
going to be traveling really fast
away from from the sun and so you don't
get a very long time to look at these
objects
we just literally zoomed past pluto and
took a million images whilst we were
there
and they're still being processed so we
we don't get long to look at these it's
really hard to enter into orbit or run
one of these things that's so far away
but we we are going there now
well right but so would you say then
that most of the objects in the kuiper
belt
are on roughly circular orbits and so
we'll never
see them unless they get jostled and set
loose and
plunged down back towards the sun yeah i
think you know that's fair to say
because there's so many millions of them
out there and and there are
we do get what we call near-earth comets
which are the ones that are diverted
towards the sun and come and visit us
but they're not that frequent like we
have quite a few of them but it doesn't
happen that often that you know
we're going to need to worry about it
too much
comet and again the near-earth comet
that's code for
comment that could one day render us
extinct oh
i just want to clarify that it's funny
because it seems like such an
innocent term and yet it's so
deadly and horrifying yeah um it was a
near-earth object that took out the
dinosaurs
really near the earth
but i was expecting you to say that the
reason comets go in sometimes these oval
shapes or whatever is because of russian
trolls
you know what i mean like they're
russian trolls can be attributed with a
lot right now
and um this might be one of them i'm
just throwing that out there
i want you to look into it look at top
people top people working on that
right now we have time for one more
before we take our first break
okay and let's go to
oh i love this question from julia casey
also from patreon
um she writes what unanswered questions
about comets do you
most want to see answered in your
lifetime
okay that's a great question right i
think one of the really hot topics at
the moment is trying to figure out
whether what what the role that comets
what was the role that comets played in
life on earth
because we don't know where we came from
we don't understand how life got here
and we don't understand how it started
on earth
we also don't understand where all our
water came from and these two things are
really linked
and we think we need water to make life
and we think we need water to sustain
life on a planet or anywhere
and but we don't understand where these
things came from and it could be
that comets and or asteroids delivered
um the building blocks for life and also
water to our planet in the past we know
they collided with us
about four and a half billion years ago
there were a lot of collisions um
of comets and asteroids into our planet
they bought all their
goodies with them and some of those
goodies were organic material and a lot
of water
so it might be that they delivered the
building blocks for life and then
we need to understand how then we got
life because it's not
good enough to say oh there's organic
matter we have life because it's not
that simple we don't understand that
next step
in science of how we produce organisms
like us
so natalie you have unique expertise
coming from a volcano
a volcano background where we know they
put water into the atmosphere and now
you're thinking about comets
so you could have the package of how to
make all the water we've ever had
well is that so yeah maybe okay so yeah
volcanoes release a lot of water they
release a lot of
a lot of gases into the atmosphere some
of them good some of them bad but they
don't actually have
a bad negative effect on on the climate
and such
but the problem is we don't know where
that water came from within the earth so
volcanoes are rocked out material from
inside the planet
um and so the material that's inside the
planet has to have been there either
from the start when the earth formed or
it was delivered later on and
incorporated into the inside of the
planet
so that it could then be erupted out and
now we may have started
all our water when our sun formed and we
formed all the planets and all the
comets and asteroids around the sun
it might be that we had all our water
from the beginning that we're actually
we've got interstellar water so our
water might actually not be
basically from our sun it might have
come from interstellar space
which would be really awesome to think
we're drinking water that's older than
our sun
but we just don't know because the earth
was really inhospitable when it first
formed it was boiling it was just a
molten ball of magma
so it's hard to understand how we might
have maintained water within that really
hot blob of magma because it probably
would have all boiled off
so this is why scientists sometimes say
okay maybe we bought that water in later
on maybe it came from
these asteroids that have a bit of ice
on them maybe it came from these comets
which are very icy
um but we just don't know so that's one
of the major questions we're trying
to answer at the moment where it all
came from and can
brita filter water that's older than the
sun
is another question this is but i
i would love for you to figure that out
that
like the explanation of life on earth
which is like
just a small answer to that question
because it
because then it explains everything like
sloths why are they such a weird animal
and cargo pants
why like it literally then explains
everything so you could be holding the
key
everything the key explainer we got to
take a quick break and when we come back
we will return to my co-host nadine
farsad
and my special guest natalie stark a
comet expert
when we return
we're back star talk cosmic queries my
co-host nadine farsad nagin
uh do you have a twitter handle in the
game yes it's nagin farsad
n-g-i-n-f-a-r-s-a-d
okay it's just your name it's just my
name
i thought when i said twitter yes i do
here it is mcgivers so unexpected
so unexpected it's my name i was ready
for
some other thing i don't know why okay i
know i really set you up for like it's
fizzle dee doo
43 you know
because so many others have stolen it
um and uh natalie natalie are you also
on twitter i am yes yeah at starkey
stardust
sorry yeah my name's starkey c negan
that's how
[Laughter]
[Music]
starkey stardust okay so we're in cosmic
queries mode
and we're talking about comets of course
inspired by the recent appearance of
comet neowise
in the sky so what what's up next do you
have there up next we have a question
from twitter
at saltzee83 asks would you expect to
find amino acids on neo-wise and could
the neo-wises of the universe
be the life distributors which you kind
of mentioned a little bit about that
before
yeah yeah we touched on this in the last
question but actually
yeah we're getting a bit more detail now
so yes we know that we've got amino
acids on comets so
i would very much expect comet neo-wise
to contain amino acids so
we've now discovered them on two comets
which is pretty much the only comets
we've studied
in detail in space the first one was
comet vilt2
which was visited by nasa stardust and
they collected samples to bring back to
earth
and they found the amino acid glycine in
it now glycine is the most simple the
most simplest amino acid
um but it's there so that's very
exciting now we
corroborated that finding with the
rosetta mission which is a european
space agency mission
and it went to uh comet 67p but it was
on the surface of the comet it actually
um put a lander down onto the surface
and it analyzed all sorts of things bits
of dust and gas that were coming off the
comet
and it and it also found amino acids on
the comet again glycine so
we know we have them we know comets
collide with the planet
and so they would have bought that
inventory of amino acids possibly other
amino acids as well we haven't found
them yet but it might be there
they brought them to our planet in the
past so there's every chance that they
did deliver
life here what we would call life
inverted comments but obviously to go
from
amino acids to complex organisms is a
really big step that we don't
currently understand so natalie what
you're saying is we were two for two
in the comments that we could have known
whether they had amino acids
so we're saying we're good with that
yeah we can assume
it's safe and it's that we've found
amino acids in asteroids a lot so
meteorite samples that are rocks
that come from asteroids and land on our
planet or they can come from other
planets as well but
the asteroid or meteorites also have
tons of amino acids in fact in one
particular asteroid example we found
more
more amino acids than we have on our
planet so there's more variation in
space than we have than we need
to account for all the life we have here
you mean more kinds of amino acids
yeah whoa whoa so life elsewhere could
just have
could be more interesting than we are it
might just rely on different
you know bundles of amino acids to make
life we have no idea we absolutely have
no idea but they're there so
that's the great thing we have it we've
got the evidence that they're all over
the solar system but now we've just got
to understand that next step of how we
get life
so nagin that's the name of your next
book how to make aliens
wait so amino asks i have a multivitamin
that contains amino acids is it
that same amino acids that you're
talking about
like it's all the same i've never really
looked at the multivitamin what is in it
but yeah
i guess so i mean because it gives me
good
uh you know nails and hair so uh
so yeah so uh comets have great updos
is basically what's going on yeah so
natalie what's going to happen is
nagin's going to visit the the meteorite
hall of the museum
she's licking the meteorites
no need to buy these supplements anymore
just go lick the meteorite
that's an excellent point neil negine
step
away from the meteorite
okay oh and just before the next
question uh natalie could you
tell me how neil wise got its name oh
yeah that's actually a really
interesting
topic i mean i could talk about this for
hours but i won't i'll try and do the
short version so
maybe a 30-second version instead comics
are generally named after the
the people that find them or in the case
of near-wise the telescope that
that found it and it's called neo-wise
it's in space it's a space telescope
um so it's probably a group of people
working on it so we couldn't just give
it one name but previously it would have
just been one person
looking through a telescope and and they
found the comment and they got to name
it after themselves so
that's what they tend to have you know
like halley's comment and all this sort
of edmund halley
um but they also have a really boring
designation so it's also called c
2020 f3 which tells you a little bit
more about the type of comet so the c
means it's non-periodic so it doesn't
come round the
sun very often there's more than 200
years it takes to go around the sun
the 2020 tells you the year it was found
or discovered
and then the f3 tells you a little bit
more about the exact month
um that it was discovered so it tells
you it's the end of
march that it was it was discovered it
was the third comet at the end of march
to be discovered
so it tells you tons of information but
we tend to just call it neowise because
it's much friendlier
i think you're underselling it a little
bit because i c
2020 slash f3 i think is going to be a
very popular baby name
coming up just wait it'll trend
born or conceived under the comet
[Laughter]
so natalie actually edmund halley didn't
discover hallie's comment
yeah really no he did not okay there we
go
i'm learning obviously i always learn
from you neil
you are the brain yeah what what he did
was he took newton's
new equations of gravity and applied it
to a comet that was in the sky
and noticed that it was the same
comet that had come around in previous
records
because now we can understand orbits you
can now think of comets
not as singular objects but as
and so so but as recurring
um visitors to the inner solar system so
using that he made a prediction
of when it would come again and so
everyone just waited
with with you know baited breath and
there it was it came right when he said
right where he said it would come and
from then on it was named after he was
long dead by then though
that's what what had happened so that's
a little cool fact it's due
back in like 2060 i guess so you know i
hope i'm still around to see that yeah
2060 yeah i think that is because it was
in 1986 as every 75 years or so
right yeah right right cool so negan
you got another question we have another
question it comes from
instagram is it possible to measure the
rate at which a comet loses its mass as
it travels across the solar system
yeah let me add to that natalie if you
do that calculation
can you tell us when it will disappear
completely
okay so the answer to both these
questions is no well no there's no
simple way to do this
but we've we've done it sort of once
really we've done it with the rosetta
mission that european space agency
mission and the only way we could do it
with that mission is because
um the orbiter and the lander were with
the comet the whole time so it they
kind of approached it when it was around
the orbit of mars jupiter kind of place
they then stayed with that comet the
whole way past the sun
and then came out the other side so what
they were able to do was look at the
processes that were happening
as this comet was heated up and its ices
were sublimating into space and it was
experiencing that very hot environment
near the sun
and as it came out the other side and
they could measure how much material was
coming off it
and what they estimated is that about a
meter of the surface of the comet was
lost during that orbit around the sun
that comet's about three by five
kilometers so a similar kind of um
size to comet neo wise but there's so
many factors that will control
how much it loses it will depend on how
much volatile material it has within it
the stuff that
that streams off into space it'll depend
what exactly is its composition how much
ice it has compared to dust
it'll depend on how close it goes to the
sun there's so many factors that will
affect that that we couldn't simply
apply that one meter rule to every comet
that goes near the sun
because that will be different but it
gives us a good idea for that particular
comet that they do lose a lot of
material and that's you know
huge amount so every time they go by the
sun that happens
and so eventually they die we kind of
say that they die they don't have any
volatile material left their ice is all
gone
so they've got no more material to lose
as they go via the sun
and then they just they don't have a
tail anymore they're no longer a comet
really
um so but it's hard to say how long
that's going to take and how many orbits
that takes to happen
so you see negan not the comment is no
longer great when that happens
wait my take away from this is that
comets are always
dieting and that basically body shaming
is happening in the solar system in a
way that i had no
idea and i am not on board with it
yeah losing a meter that's that's that's
a
[Laughter]
so lily the the comet is little is being
flayed by the sun
that's that's sad i know i know but
then we wouldn't see them otherwise
because unless that process happened as
comets kind of reach the orbit around
jupiter and that's when they start to
get heated up and that's when they'll
start to produce what we call this coma
which is
the kind of the atmosphere that
surrounds that rocky
nucleus and that makes up the comet so
they start to get heated up and the
the ice within them there's lots of
different types of ice in a comet it
could be water ice carbon monoxide
carbon dioxide
methane ammonia lots of different types
of big cubes they use and bars
is that in there too there is so common
yeah we've got dry ice because that
would be the carbon dioxide stuff so
basically they all um get sublimated
which means they turn from
solid to gas at different stages as
they're going towards the sun the first
ones come off as generally carbon
monoxide and that kind of glows blue so
if you often see images of comet
neo-wise they've got this kind of blue
halo around
the comet nucleus and that starts to
then stream off into the tail of that
material
and so that's actually just the comet
losing its mass and that all that
material is just streaming out behind it
along with dust particles that are
coming off at the same time so it's
it's kind of can be quite a violent
environment on the surface of the comet
as
different portions of it get heated up
differently and then jets of
gases can shoot off and it can be quite
crazy
so natalie everything i know about that
i learned from
the movie armageddon
when they landed on the surface of the
comet and it rotates into the sunlight
and then you know geysers start popping
out and
yeah yeah i don't want to say that was
the only accurate part about that
you have a mental image at least i do i
do
so nagin what else you have okay and we
also have from twitter
um oh hello from cape verde which is
such an
exotic location to be sending a message
from
i think they're volcanic islands aren't
they nice yeah i think so yeah
it's like my dream to go visit my dear
friends uh theoretically can we harvest
water from asteroids and comets to solve
water crises and famines here on earth
and if so wouldn't that seem more
important slash practical than starting
a colony
on mars no i mean before you get to that
natalie let me just say we had an entire
live star talk live program on water
not only on earth but in the solar
system and i had not fully appreciated
how much rarer potable
fresh water is becoming on earth yeah
you know water water all around and not
a drop
to drink so what is the nature of the
water on comets and why can't we just
lasso one and bring it in make a lake of
it and
and dip in our straws well yeah the
thing is
first of all obviously we're going to be
much better place looking after our own
water supplies
making fresh clean water for ourselves
and not polluting the rest of our planet
um and having a lot of salt water is a
problem because obviously we don't want
to drink salt
water now when we go into space and
there are other
moons and stuff that have water on them
but it tends to be salty water
that's good for life and that life can
survive in there but it's not
stuff that we want to drink so sure
enough if we were to travel
out into space and we wanted to go and
you know live on mars
not sure that's going to be a good idea
but anyway if we did we would need water
and there's no water on mars that we
don't think there's much anyway um there
might be some in the subsurface but it's
we don't know
so we could kind of travel by a comet on
the way and and
get some water we could just melt some
of that comet separate out the water ice
from you know all those other types of
ices that it contained
and sure enough we could use that in
space and we do think that um
that is one of the ways we might be able
to explore further into the solar system
um but it has its problems we it just
it's not going to be very easy to do
just kind of fly by comment and grab
some water it's not that simple
and but it's definitely not something
we'll be doing to bring back to earth
it's not going to be practical
to transport water back to our planet
and even though there's a lot of in
space
we're better off looking after our own
water here so there's an interesting
corollary to that because it still costs
nasa about 10
000 a pound to put a payload into space
so if i launch you and you want to drink
16 ounces of water sorry i'm using
imperial units here that you guys gave
us from the uk
apologies let me check my bottle that's
about 500 mils
yeah about 500 milliliters that's
correct uh
so if it costs ten thousand dollars to
launch
a pint of water into space so that you
can drink it later
if i set up a mining colony that mines
frozen water from us from asteroids and
comets melts it
then i sell it to nasa but for on space
activities
and i'll sell to nasa for seven thousand
dollars yeah
i i can do that and then if something
gets cheap i'll sell it for five
thousand whatever
but i can imagine a future
however distant where the water that we
do harvest from comets goes to other
activities in space
rather than i agree it'd be impractical
just to bring it back to earth
yeah and at the moment anybody that goes
up and grabs an object in space like an
asteroid or a comet can own i think
pretty much american citizens anyway can
own whatever they find in space i have a
feeling the rest of the world is
catching up with those
laws um so yeah you could do that if you
could go and mine a comet and asteroid
you can for sure
then sell it whatever materials you get
from it to whoever wants them
that's been an american rule ever since
the beginning we find it and then it's
hours
how the how the country was built that's
right
but the really cool thing about water is
that you can also use it as um
propulsion for for rocket fuel so you
could if you can split the hydrogen and
the oxygen out of the water
or to being h2o molecule um and the
hydrogen and the oxygen then you can use
that
um as propulsion as well so it's not
just for humans living but it's also to
get
further into space because as you said
launching anything off our planet is
incredibly expensive because we have a
lot of gravity
so if we can get our fuel in space
without having to take it with us from
the earth
that's a real bonus as well yeah
excellent
all right and
negan we also we've got a question from
instagram um
from gabriel joaquim how do different
chemical compositions
change the color of the comet
nice question because i've seen pictures
of the comet and there's all these
beautiful colors in it
i want to know where that comes from
except we have to take a break
[Applause]
we come back we will all learn
from natalie starkey how comets get
their colors
on star talk
we're back star talk cosmic queries
comets
i've got nagin facade my co-host and
natalie starkey
who's our resident comet expert except
she's in the uk right now
so she's a resident of somewhere
yeah so nagin somebody just asked about
comet colors is that right
that's right they asked um what like how
do different chemical compositions
change
the color of the comet so how does the
leopard get its spots
and how do comets get their colors see
this should be in the same book
it's yeah that's a great question
because it's one of the ways we can
figure out
what comets are made of because we can
look at their colours as they come into
the inner solar system
and it tells us what is literally coming
off their surface which isis are
sublimating and turning from solid to
gas as they they get hotter so i
mentioned earlier that the first gas um
that tends to come off is carbon
monoxide and that blows blue
neil can probably explain the physics
reason behind
all the ions interacting and why that
glows blue do you want to
no
[Laughter]
but it glows blue let's just say there's
some interaction with the physics no i
can tell you like
i can tell you so these these molecules
um
have certain sort of energy states and
that they exist in and if they're fed
another energy source
they can you can kick electrons off of
them or you can
bump them up into a higher energy state
and then they
release that energy back to you but in a
very specific part of the spectrum
and then you so and different compounds
different different molecules different
atoms have different colors
corresponding to what their energy
levels are
so that it's it's not deeper than that
and that's going on all the time
so yeah so go on that natalie you see
this that's the exam question isn't it
that i should
my high school chemistry teacher will be
like oh natalia you should know this
stuff
by the way do you remember the
glow-in-the-dark frisbees you know you
you put it under a light and then you'd
throw
a play frisbee anywhere yeah it glows
this kind of pale green
well when you put it under regular light
and it bumps up
the energy levels and then when you take
it away from the light
the electrons descend
and emit this green light corresponding
to the material that's in the
in the in the frisbee itself so and it
doesn't do that forever right you only
get to play with it for 10 or 15 minutes
before you don't see that
signature at all but the comet is
constantly getting stoked by the sun
so you get these colors sustained you
can sometimes get a green color which i
think
is related to um elemental carbon
because we know there's a lot of carbon
in comets um
the dust particles tend to be made up of
carbon hydrogen oxygen and nitrogen
particles
so all the staff for life it's brilliant
and you can also sometimes get a red
tail
um which is so with comets you tend to
have two main tails the first one is
is made of dust and that can be quite
diffuse it tends to be sort of either
white gray kind of yellow colored you
get the second tail which is the ion
tail which is these gases that have come
off and that
tends to be blue or greeny colored and
then sometimes there's this sodium
tail which is red and i think actually
it was seen with comet near-wise there
were three different tails coming off
this comet
so you've got the comet traveling
towards the sun and these tails all
face away from the sun basically right
so tail
is a misnomer on its way out of the
solar system
out of the inner solution right if it
goes out tail first we think of tail as
something that
trails yeah exactly it's only trailing
on its way in
yeah the tail ends up ahead of the
comments or the tails
but they're not all in line with each
other because obviously the dust and the
ion gases they get
distributed differently and they react
differently to the gravity of the sun
and the solar wind and everything so
they end up being separated and that's
how you can see them and
i mean some of the images that people
have got of this comment have been
absolutely aren't they beautiful
yeah and everybody's got a great camera
and you don't need full telescopes to do
this anymore
just a camera with a good lens yeah not
like the the old days i sound like an
old man
my
can we go to lightning lightning rounds
actually it's not up to you it's up to
natalie to answer questions
okay let's see pretend you're on the
evening news and they just want sound
bites
okay so this is your sound by quiz okay
so nagin what do you have all right rob
uh kirsten
from the netherlands writes on instagram
let's say uh comments oh by the way by
the way john ort who is from the
netherlands
oh there it is just full circle the
the dutch have had a long uh in the 20th
century
a very long and proud history of
participating in cosmic discovery
just thought i'd give a toss out to the
dutch but go on okay uh does comet haley
always have the same tail tail color
every time it comes around the sun
the chemical composition burns but can a
comet gain other
chemical compositions on its way to us
um yeah so it'll i think it should
theoretically always glow the same color
because it will have the same
ices within it but as they get depleted
i guess it could change color with each
orbit of the sun
but it definitely isn't going to gain
any material as it goes by the sun it
will
only be losing stuff good short answer
let me ask
could there be a layer below that's
different from the layers above
that then gets revealed as a new
chemical signature completely
we have no idea because we haven't
studied enough comments up close and we
haven't studied enough
over the course of an orbit so yeah we
don't know they could be completely
different as they go as you drill down
into them it's great we have no idea
lots to find out it's like a seven layer
nacho dip
more to discover okay jeff bearstow
writes on twitter is comet neowise's
dust likely to result in future
predictable meteor showers
oh actually i don't know the answer to
that question but um
i i guess it could do you know the
answer to this one
yeah so i think any um i mean it depends
on the orbital inclination
it's not just whether the comet emits uh
releases dust
the comet's path actually has to cross
earth's orbit
yeah and obviously you don't want to be
there when that happens
okay you want to be there at a different
time when the crosses
but then the dust that gets laid into
its orbit we would then plow through it
creating a brand new meteor shower
so i haven't checked i think this one is
oriented in a way that we're not
actually passing through the table i
think that's the case as well
yeah right that's right we
have from oxford comma 20
on twitter how many oxford comma 20.
we've got a literate person here okay
how many encounters with the inner solar
system do comets from the kuiper belt
and ort cloud get before they're totally
steam cleaned and become plain old
asteroids
oh i like that so we had a similar
question earlier and actually
it's again we don't know we don't really
know if any individual comment how long
it's going to take for it to just die
and lose
all its ices so we just have to study
each one in detail and then
once we see what it does on its first
orbit that we look at it we've got to
wait till it comes back and see how it
reacts again
we really have no idea but we have
observed comments that are then
dead so we know that that can happen um
but how long it takes for that to happen
we really don't know at the moment so
when you say dead you don't mean
destroyed you mean
there's nothing to evaporate to render
it visible exactly so they just end up
as like a hunk of rock in the end
what fraction of a comet's mass is ice
relative to rock
um so again it varies
there's a whole range of compositions so
we can't just say
any comet is 80 ice and 20 rock and we
have to study each one individually
and to work out its density and then
work out how much rock it has within it
and also different ices and
a different composition of ice has a
different density it's very hard to work
out
actually what a comet is made of any
individual comet anyway we can only say
in very general terms that they are
icy dust balls or dusty ice balls or
whatever
what i'm gathering from all of this is
that comets are a really fickle lover
you know you just don't know what
they're gonna do how they feel you just
don't know
we also heard from michael strzok on
instagram he asks how many comets
are there in or near the solar system at
any given time
so within the inner solar system um what
we did at the moment with telescopes
like the neowise telescope that
discovered the neowest comet
is that we're kind of tracing all the
bigger objects that we can see so this
includes asteroids and comets
and what we're doing that for is to kind
of figure out what all that's they're on
in case there's any that are going to
oppose any threat to our own planet and
we would call those um
hazardous asteroids or comets or
potentially hazardous asteroids or
comments
um so we know where many of them are
and there's thousands of them that come
within the inner solar system
all the time um but i couldn't tell you
the exact number i think it's it's kind
of like hundreds of
comets over the size of you know one
kilometer and and things like that but
yeah you can look at the numbers that it
is all online because i was actually
looking at this the other day but
those numbers are not as you'd expect
this there are many more smaller ones
than there are larger ones
yeah right and so and fortunately it's
the large ones that you can detect that
would do the most damage if they hit us
right it would be diabolical if the
little ones that you can't see did all
the damage
uh that would just be unfair in the
universe
uh but but yeah so and and of course if
you add up all the comments in the
in the work cloud we've got billions and
billions i think
yes yeah yeah yeah so negan keep going
all right uh if you get two more we got
like one minute left okay we have two
more here we go natalie's on a roll
she's
knocking these out from real tired hours
on instagram
um i want to know if comets orbit all
the same direction in the same way
planets do and if not what would it look
like if two
comets collided while visible from earth
with the naked eye
i want to know that too yeah that would
be so
cool okay so we've seen comets
disintegrate when they go near the sun i
mentioned this earlier when you know
these things are very volatile
they are very fragile because they're
made they're basically a snowball with a
bit of dirt in so if they go too close
to the sun they can
explode and we have sort of seen that
with
a telescope before and but if two would
collide in space well
it's unlikely to happen but if it were
to happen we would basically see these
things sort of collide and disintegrate
it might not be as exciting as you might
think cause like if you had two rocks
colliding because they probably just
sort of
melt into each other a little bit um but
if they were to collide in in the outer
solar system
um they're going pretty kind of it's
kind of quite far apart out there and
they're not kind of
going to hit each other with very much
force so if they were to collide way out
in the outer cell stem we wouldn't
really see much
we wouldn't be able to see it happen
anyway but it i don't think it would be
very exciting
oh natalie you're bumming us out this
was a great question now you turned it
into like
no it's not going to be exciting yeah
like i was like
i was geared up for like the macy's
fireworks display
and instead you're like oh no this is
like the sad like larry outside of
sheboygan doing fireworks off his roof
you know that's what we're gonna see i
just they're so fragile and i think
nothing
like if if they come into they can
collide with our planet and they have
done in the past but actually
the only time we've ever kind of
observed this happening um
they kind of explode as they come
through the atmosphere because they just
can't
maintain their shape because they're
just not consolidated enough they're not
held together very well
and they tend to explode in the
atmosphere before they even reach the
surface of the planet so
yeah i don't think it'd be very exciting
all right all right here's your last
question last question
last question go last question is from
dudesprea on facebook
is it possible for a probe to hitch a
ride on a comet maybe
an extra solar comet that'll leave the
solar system
oh a lovely question i like this one so
yeah of course we've done this with the
european space agency mission there was
zeta mission which i've mentioned a few
times because it was just one of these
groundbreaking missions to a comet
it landed a little lambda on the side of
the comet and as i said it followed that
comet then
as it went via the sun and came out the
other side um
and it's still there so this comet is
now heading out into the outer solar
system again
and that little lander is still with it
and they even had an orbiter with that
comment which they
basically crash landed onto the comet
because they were like we can't do any
science now there's no
sun we need sun to have for our solar
panels
what are we going to do with this
spacecraft we'll just crash land it
or decelerate it into the comet so
they're now with it
now if you did that with a comet like a
muammua and it was going
out of the solar system at great speed
then sure you could then hit your ride
you'd have trouble with power and it's
very cold as you get away from the sun
so spacecraft don't really like that but
it is possible
uh let me add that it's not so much that
you're hitching a ride
because if you matched speeds to
the interstellar object
then once you match speeds you don't
have to attach to it
because you will have the exact
trajectory that a muammar would have
so it's an interesting fact it's not
like you just hook it and then it pulls
you along
it's your match you've matched speeds
you're there
you are with the comment whether you're
touching it or not
that's just the physics of it but
natalie i think it's a it's funny to
think
that we've got our hardware sitting on a
comet so that with the
with the rosetta mission so the next
time it comes around if it's jostled
loose
there's like a spacecraft get it
getting jettison off the back of a car
and that's what they were worried about
when the comet went via the sun the
lander may have just been
thrown off into space if a big jet of
you know gases had shot off the comet
when it got heated up so
yeah it was a real we had no idea what
was gonna happen because we've never
done it before so yeah
i am super prone to motion sickness so
the
idea of hitching a ride on a comic just
sounds
horrifying to me it just sounds like a
vomit bag a constant
use of a vomit bag yeah there's been a
lot as well
no no no no thank you you should be more
worried worried about
a jet spewing forth under you
and then casting you back out into space
rather than just being on the comet
and worried that you might need some
drama meeting
so we got to end it there nagin it's
always
great to have you i always it's the
second time hope to see more of you as
my co-host
so fun i learned so much and your book
how to make white people laugh
crazy title um and even crazier
uh podcast title uh what does it do the
nations
fake the nation uh good luck with those
and we hope to see you again and natalie
always good to see